>> WE HAVE ALREADY SEEN A BLACK
PRESIDENT AND FIRST FAMILY.
NOW WE WANT TO KNOW WHAT IT IS
GOING TO MEAN.
SYMBOLISM IS NOT ENOUGH NOW.
IT IS SUBSTANCE.
AND IF THERE IS NO SUBSTANCE,
THEN WE'VE GOTTEN OVER THE ARIA
OF THE FIRST.
>> Laura: THOSE COMMENTS ALONG
WITH OTHERS AT THE NATIONAL
ACTION NETWORK WERE DRIPPING
WITH GRIEVANCE.
THEY LED ME TO POSE THIS
QUESTION YESTERDAY.
TODAY IS ANNIVERSARY OF THE
ASSASSINATION OF THE REVEREND
MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR.
I WAS THINKING IF HE WERE ALIVE
TODAY, I WONDER WHAT HE WOULD
THINK ABOUT SUCH DISMISSIVE
COMMENTS?
AND ABOUT A DEMOCRAT PARTY THAT
BELIEVES IT CAN REGAIN POWER BY
LIVING IN A CONSTANT STATE OF
PROTEST OR RACIAL HATRED AND
DENIAL?
FOR HIGHLIGHTING HOW THE
MANUFACTURED OUTRAGE BY SOME OF
THE SOCIAL JUSTICE WARRIORS IS
CREATING RACIAL DIVISION AND
HATRED.
I WAS ATTACKED JUST ASKING A
QUESTION.
KIND OF IN THE RESPONSE TO
PROVING MY POINT.
THEY AREN'T INTERESTED IN THE
STATE OF -- CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM, SCHOOL CHOICE, ALL THE
THINGS THAT CONSERVATIVES LOVE.
INSTEAD THEY ATTEMPT TO
DEMONIZE ANYONE WHO REJECTS
DIVISIVE, NEGATIVE WAY OF
THINKING.
THEY WANT TO SHUT DOWN SPEECH.
THEY DON'T BELIEVE IN OPEN
DIALOGUE.
JOINING ME NOW IS A WOMAN WHO
DOES, ALVEDA KING, NIECE OF
MARTIN LUTHER KING, JUNIOR.
HAS THE TYPE OF STUFF YOU'RE
SEEING FROM JESSE JACKSON AND
ALL THE DEMOCRATS, ONE AFTER
THE OTHER AFTER THE OTHER
BOWING DOWN TO HIS IDENTITY
OVER THE LAST FEW DAYS, I JUST
RAISE THE QUESTION BECAUSE IT
IS SO NEGATIVE.
EVEN OBAMA'S PRESIDENCY WAS
DISMISSED BY AL SHARPTON SAYING
HE DID GOOD THINGS BUT NOW IT'S
ON TO THE REAL WORK.
>> ISN'T THAT AMAZING THAT AL
SHARPTON WOULD SAY THAT?
HE FORGETS MANY THINGS QUICKLY.
I THINK HE FORGOT MARTIN LUTHER
KING, JUNIOR WAS A PROPHET.
JESSE JACKSON FORGOT THAT, TOO.
IN THE SPIRIT OF JESUS CHRIST
IT SOUNDS LIKE SOCIALISM TO SAY
FEED THE POOR AND TAKE CARE OF
THE HUNGRY.
THAT'S THE PERSPECTIVE OF
MARTIN LUTHER KING.
>> Laura: SOME OF YOUR
RELATIVES WERE TWEETING ABOUT
THIS.
YOU NEVER KNOW WHAT ANYONE
WOULD THINK.
WHAT WOULD THOMAS JEFFERSON
THINK?
I WAS WATCHING A LOT OF HIS
SPEECHES BEFORE THE SHOW AND
GOING BACK AND WATCHING.
HE WAS SOUNDING MORE FAVORABLE
TO SOCIALISM AND THEIR IDEAS.
ONE OF HIS SPEECHES WE HAVE THE
FULL SCREEN WHEN HE TALKED
ABOUT SOCIALISM.
THIS IS A DESCRIPTION OF HIM.
DR. KING WAS ANTI-WAR,
ANTI-CAPITALISM AND PRO
SOCIALISM.
HE SAW CAPITALISM AN ECONOMIC
STRUCTURE THAT BREAD POVERTY
AND INJUSTICE AND CHANGE
SOCIETY INTO A DEMOCRATIC FORM
OF SOCIALISM WHICH THE WORKERS
OWN AND DIRECT PROFIT IN WHICH
THEY WORKED AND PRODUCED AN
EXTREMELY WEALTHY UPPER CLASS
BUT LEFT OTHERS IN DIRE POVERTY.
HIS ACTUAL SPEECHES FROM KING
WHERE HE DISCUSSED THE NEED TO
FUNDAMENTALLY RESTRUCTURE THE
ECONOMIC SYSTEM IN THE UNITED
STATES.
SO MAYBE THE PUSH TOWARD
SOCIALISM IS IN THE TRADITION
OF HIM?
>> NOT EXACTLY SOCIALISM.
HE WOULD WANT TO SEE
AFRICAN-AMERICANS TODAY OWN
LAND, OWN PROPERTY, WORK,
CONTRIBUTE TO SOCIETY.
SO HE WOULD NOT NECESSARILY
HAVE SUPPORTED JUST HAND-OUTS
WITHOUT HAND UP AND EQUIPPING
PEOPLE TO FISH FOREVER RATHER
THAN HAVING A FISH FOR A DAY.
HIS SOCIALISM WAS MORE
REMINDFUL OF CHRIST RATHER THAN
A POLITICAL STRUCTURE OR SYSTEM.
BUT AS FAR AS PERPETUAL
PROTEST, HE WAS SEWING SEEDS OF
HOPE.
ONE DAY THIS WILL END AND WE'LL
ALL HAVE SOMETHING TOGETHER.
THAT'S THE MARTIN LUTHER KING
JUNIOR THAT I KNOW.
>> Laura: HE WAS WORKING WITH
PEOPLE IN BOTH PARTIES.
THE CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT TODAY
IT -- YOU DON'T
>> IT HAS TO BE EITHER/OR.
IF YOU'RE AN AFRICAN-AMERICAN
EVERYBODY INSISTS YOU NEED TO
BE A DEMOCRAT AND MARTIN LUTHER
KING JUNIOR WAS AN INDEPENDENT.
HIS DAD STARTED OUT AS A
REPUBLICAN.
HE WAS AN INDEPENDENT.
WHY SHARPTON FORGETS.
IF WE FORGET OUR HISTORY WE'LL
FORGET THE BAD PART AND FORGET
TO DO THE GOOD LIFE OVER AGAIN.
>> Laura: YOU DO SO MUCH GREAT
WORK FOR THE PRO-LIFE COMMUNITY.
>> CIVIL RIGHTS FOR THE UNBORN.
I'M GLAD TO SEE MORE AND MORE
BEING DONE.
WE NEED TO END RACISM, ABORTION
AND INFANTICIDE FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE.
>> Laura: THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
YOU CALL HIM DADDY KING IN HIS
CORE.
>> HE WAS ALWAYS PRO-LIFE FROM
BIRTH UNTIL WHEN HE LEFT THE